SPEAKER: Creating a good
user experience for customers
and the teams that
maintain a chatbot agent
are both very important.
And so in this episode of
Deconstructing Chatbots,
we will share seven
best practices that
will tie in key
pro moves you may
have seen in our prior lessons,
but we'll touch more upon now.
So stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The first step is
to future-proof
the names of intents.
As your agent supports a
greater variety of topics,
the more successful the
collaboration with others
will be by using explicit names.
A common practice
is to format them
as your intention
dot expected action.
Four common examples
of these intents
are for information
collection, confirmation,
supplemental questions, and
redirecting to live agents.
Let's go through each.
For example, when
collecting information
for helping a customer to
purchase shoes for their pups,
you can name your
intent shoes dot book
to collect parameters
such as color and size.
Next, as a user navigates
through your flows,
it's good to confirm and repeat
back if the information was
correct or not.
Ergo, having two intents
called confirmation
dot yes and confirmation
dot no are useful.
And we'll talk more about these
benefits using confirmation
yes no intents in a bit.
Then there are questions that
customers may have that are not
core to your purchasing
flow, but you
know are frequently asked.
Let's call these supplementals.
For example, customers are more
interested in sustainability
and frequently ask Pugs--
are your products
sustainably sourced?
Or may have questions
about their account.
And as a fourth type of intent,
known as redirect dot support
team, is meant to
allow customers
to eject out of the flow
to speak to a live person.
Next, let's talk about reusing
intents and pages via the route
group functionality.
By designing your agent
with reusability in mind,
it helps save time answering
the same intent from anywhere
in the journey.
You can do this by
creating multiple intents
and putting them together
in a route group once.
And just modify every page
to allow for that same group
to be used.
For example, you can put
100 supplemental intents
at the beginning of
the flow and at the end
during the confirmation
pages to enable
users to ask questions
outside of the flow
and be brought back to the
flow after getting answers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Next, you can train your
agent with phrases in bulk
by uploading them.
This can be done by
visiting the desired intent
and clicking the Upload icon
to upload a CSV or txt file.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Next tip is to add rephrased
variations of questions
when you have
required parameters,
since it will not stop
asking this question
until it gets collected.
And it's good to rephrase the
question up to three times,
then to pass a
customer to a human
to avoid a bad user experience
if the third try doesn't help.
This is a great rule of thumb,
by the way, that all of us
have experienced at
some point as consumers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And for yes/no questions,
you want to say,
did I get that right?
And leverage the confirmation
dot yes or no intents.
This brings us to
the next point.
It's beneficial to
reduce ambiguity
by repeating back
what a person heard,
as it builds trust
with the user.
Ergo, by using the money symbol
and the name of the entity
in the fulfillment
section, which
is the reply to the
customer by the agent,
you can reaffirm to the customer
what was understood from them.
This applies to both
the extensive list
of system entities built into
dialogue flows such as color
or date, for example,
or custom ones you
build that you do not find as
a system entity, such as size.
Next, to enable a user to
erase their past intent,
for example--
I want red shoes.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
You make an intent route
called "go back" and make
the parameter ask to null.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And finally, it's important
to be testing your agent
as frequently as
possible when building it
bit by bit to catch
errors faster.
You can do this by going to
the test agent functionality
on the top right side.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And there you have it--
seven best practices for
building a robust agent that
creates a positive user
experience both for end
users and those who've
maintained the agent.
I hope to see you in the next
episode for deconstructing
chatbots.
If you like this
video and would like
to see more of
such content, don't
forget to like and subscribe,
as well as to check out
the helpful links I have listed
in this video subscription.
Cheers, and thank
you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]